carlos a donc passé sa deuxième nuit en
prison le terroriste mise en examen hier
par le juge bruguière a été placé sous
mandat de dépôt carlos est détenu sous
le régime ordinaire à la prison de la
santé mais pour ce prisonnier peu
ordinaire les syndicats de gardiens de
prison demande plus de moyens claude
sans père réjean paul guilloteau
un dps un détenu particulièrement
surveillé
carlos vient de passer sa deuxième nuit
à la maison d'arrêt de la santé à paris
troisième division dans un quartier
spécial le quartier d'isolement
carlos est au rez de chaussée au
deuxième étage se trouve le docteur
garetta et paul toungui ici tout est
fait pour que les détenus ne se
rencontrent jamais
il faut donc quatre personnels de
surveillance n'ont regardé plus abordé
en permanence donc pour carlos et donc
pour la mesure d'isolement chaque fois
qu'il fait un mouvement en dehors de sa
cellule il doit être accompagné par par
nos collègues que je n'ai cité donc à
partir de la 4 sur les impulsions gradé
pour simplement une personne ça fait
beaucoup quand on sait qu'il ya
énormément de détenus donc à notre à
s'occuper ceci dit ça fait partie de
notre boulot ou simplement il nous
manque des effectifs et c'est ce qu'on
réclame depuis des années et au delà
c'est le problème des structures est ce
que nous souhaitons depuis toujours des
établissements spécialisés pour garder
effectivement ce genre d'individu
particulièrement dangereux pour la
société et notre job c'est de le garder
et de garder en toute sécurité
pour le reste carlos est soumis à un
régime de détention ordinaire
radiotélévision cigarettes boissons non
alcoolisées en revanche il est seule en
promenade et il peut déjeuner à la
cantine mais en horaires décalés
deux fois par semaine il recevra la
visite d'un médecin qui peut émettre un
avis sur le maintien ou non en isolement
selon le ministère de la justice la
santé offre toutes les garanties de
sécurité l avantage d'être proche du
palais de justice carlos devrait donc y
rester jusqu'à son procès